i'm the leader of the free world
[Music]
all right everybody focus up look this
party tonight
could be a model for the way that the
world should work
and i just want to say i'm totally
stoked to the max about it
all right you guys feeling good yeah oh
dennis what are you shooting video yeah
man all right well be careful with that
i might run for office someday
now trust me i think that this party can
be
the most inspirational party this campus
has ever seen is that coming to me
and just grab that
it's a righteous bug it's a righteous
belt we got going on there
we need some bodacious jock babes coming
in yeah we need some hot ass punk rock
babes
i i i don't care where they come from
the most important thing it's imperative
that we have a diversity in the uh
uh [ __ ] department intercepted don't
sleep on barrio
don't ever sleep on barrio
that is some major dopage
apartheid is totally gnarly
it's a gnarly institution where is he
dennis that there you go come here
get this get this okay we gotta have a
system in place to get everybody
weed all right so just watch this is how
you're gonna do it all right this
this i'm really frosty right now by the
way
this is your constitution all right it's
just a piece of paper
we gotta keep its integrity because it's
gonna hold everything together this
right here
this is us this is the american people
we're special we're magic
hello yay we all live in here all right
the most important thing
is that we don't get too far apart me
and you we gotta be close that's that's
the magic of america's love
otherwise they're gonna get air bubbles
in there it's gonna start canoeing and
everything we don't want that all right
you get that
all right look my way ahead of you but
i'm already done
boom fireworks fourth of july that's for
you we want like 10 of these
oh my god i'm so blessed
i'm so oh
what was i saying
when i roll down the street brother's
all taking me honey's dropping their g's
run pieces of me cause i run this whole
block with these rhymes
and this glide make this whole damn hood
tick this my tongue i'm the toss
[ __ ] of the walk i'm the boss and the
king [ __ ] kissing my ass and [ __ ]
kissing my ring
what's up yeah you know it's true
i'm the leader of the free world
thank you i mean god bless america
all right a couple introductions with
the chat here this is john o'rourke nice
to meet you josh
ian roberts nice to meet peter tencio
all right
nice to meet you jerome smith come on
brother what's up fam
you know this keith williamson nice to
meet you mary woodbury
nice to meet you jay martel nice to meet
you sir tasha robinson
come on come on come on
feel that emily george all right
nice to meet you daryl stokes come on
what's up fam
how you doing all right never forget
about that
cause that's all we got nice to meet you
all right oh bring it down bring me down
starting from the bottom now we're here
yeah nice to meet you
all right nice to meet you all right
nice to meet you
1 8th black afternoon in my octa room
come on bring it in there tuck that up
i'm in the dog i'm in there i'm
nice to meet you man uh nice to meet you
oh my goodness look at this
oh she is so beautiful
um i want another one
there you go precious beautiful
beautiful what's her name oh this is
livia roojie okay
nice to meet you miss rougey all right
come on mario
boom all right very good to meet you all
right here we go
right this way sir
come on come on come on this is
something i got my man's
10 minutes okay the number pressing no
no
just hold on a second malia all right
just hold on a second sorry everyone
it was uh taking so long
obama how you doing sir
it's me just uh showing my daughter how
to use the atm
having a little trouble with the machine
oh you having trouble with the machine
oh man we tripping we're chipping right
now man then you could be on your way no
no no no
no no i'm trying to show malia what life
is like in the real world here
all right so just do me a favor treat me
like you would anyone else in this
situation okay yes sir yes sir all right
ah hurry up man is your time stuck in
the damn machine
[ __ ] not exactly what i have in mind
come on girl hurry up man you got seven
oh okay take your time take your time
take your time all right you're doing
fine sweetie
now uh malia let's just go easy on the
gas here and come to a complete stop
okay so in the future you want to try
not to go through
stop signs
okay just remain calm now and uh what
you're going to want to do is pull up
right here uh next to the curb
this is this is why we want to stay in
the lines and we want to follow rules
remember this
license and registration
holy mr president yeah yeah
just uh teaching malia to drive
well you guys ran a stop sign back there
but that's okay you can go oh no no no
no
well malia's got to learn what it's like
to drive in the real world here well
this is called consequences malia
now i want you to go ahead and treat us
like you would if i weren't the
president
not exactly what i had in mind
[Music]
oh honey i am tired i'm going to bed
good night uh
well is everything okay
well it's uh it's just that i was uh
hoping that uh well that we could
and uh i i want to make this clear uh
i i want to be uh straightforward i want
to uh
have a okay uh luther are you available
to translate yes ma'am
i really was hoping we could spend some
time together when is the last time we
had sex woman re-election night what
does a brother not named bill clinton
have to do to get some
in this house well you have been very
busy
lately you know what
if i could can we get your translator oh
yes certainly uh
katendra
yeah honey could you please translate
well you have been very busy
lately sure my
one of your limousines that you can jump
in and out of whenever you feel like
i don't see you all day then you want a
booty car
i need an emotional connection
thought this was uh romantic i'm trying
[ __ ] can't you see
i'm playing the romantic music i got the
pinot and the glasses
what more do you want from me an
engraved invitation from my nuts
maybe we should make a date what am i
supposed to do
jump out of my clothes every time little
bear stands at attention
you ain't my commander-in-chief mother
and my vagina ain't some cave in the
middle east
you can fly your heat-seeking missile
into whenever you feel
like it well
i didn't mean to call you but i had
meetings all day long
i'm dealing with these mother
republicans hearing no no
no all day long then i come home and
you're gonna let me get my jam on up in
here
well you know i have had a busy day too
you act like i ain't got nothing else to
do i got these old beasts [ __ ]
on my ass 24
7. what's more important you getting
your wig dipped
or some eight-year-old fat ass
collapsing his bunk bed
okay you seem to be forgetting job
number one
you are my secretary of [ __ ] get
to work you
yeah we'll uh we'll take it from here
absolutely yes sir
oh this feels good um mom
dad i know you already said that i can't
go but can i please go to the party
tonight
malia use your translator
if you don't let me go to this party i
will get a tattoo
on my face have fun
[Music]
now first let me just say that i'm
encouraged that so many of you from the
republican party
have agreed to meet me in this way
now as you know i've tried very hard to
reach across the aisle
and govern this country from the middle
well
oh due respect mr president
we disagree with you we think you should
run the country from
not the middle well that's why we're
here
uh if you would i'd just appreciate some
feedback on some new ideas and
directions for this country
feel free to agree or disagree
whatever you want we're gonna disagree
i disagree disagree
first i think the government is too big
i think we need to shrink the size of
the federal government so that all
decisions can be made at the state level
we disagree mr president
you drive a hard bargain you win
there we go big
government it is
next up this has been a hot button issue
but i think we can settle it right here
no taxes for rich people we completely
disagree
round two goes to you guys okay
more taxes for the rich okay what the
what is happening to us and i am taking
a beating here guys
all right last issue immigration now
we need to secure our borders and
anybody who's here illegally should be
hunted down
and
[Music]
if we deported
[Music]
we are a country of immigrants no
we need a clear path to citizenship for
all of those who are already
here
[Music]
great i love your ideas lastly we cannot
regulate firearms
yes we can
all right all right you guys say
something
and nobody better throw me a cigarette
ain't i a stinker
[Music]
oh